hello world my name is Professor David J
malen I teach computer science at
Harvard and I'm here today to answer
your questions from Twitter this is
computer science support
[Music]
first up from Tad proletarian how do
search engines work so fast well the
short answer really is distributed
computing which is to say that Google
and Bing and other such search engines
they don't just have one server and they
don't even have just one really big
server rather they have hundreds
thousands probably hundreds of thousands
or more servers nowadays around the
world and so when you and I go in O2
Google or Bing and maybe type in a word
to search for like cat it's quite
possible that when you hit enter and
that keyword like cats is sent over the
internet to Google or to Bing it's
actually spread out ultimately across
multiple servers some of which are
grabbing the first 10 results some of
which are grabbing the next 10 results
the next 10 results so that you see just
one collection of results but a lot of
those ideas a lot of those search
results came from different places and
this eliminates what could potentially
be a bottleneck of sorts if all of the
information you needed had to come from
one specific server that might very well
be busy when you have that question Nick
asks will computer programming jobs to
be taken over by AI within the next five
to ten years this is such a frequently
Asked question nowadays and I don't
think the answer will be yes and I think
we've seen evidence of this already in
that early on when people were creating
websites they were literally writing out
code in a language called HTML by hand
but then of course software came along
tools like Dreamweaver that you could
download on your own computer that would
generate some of that same code for you
more recently though now you can just
sign up for websites like Squarespace
and Wix and others whereby click click
click and the website is generated for
you so I dare say certainly in some
domains that AI is really just an
evolution of that Trend and it hasn't
put humans out of business as much as it
has made you and I much more productive
AI I think and the ability soon to be
able to program with natural language is
just going to enhance what you and I can
already do logically but much more
mechanically and I think too it's worth
considering that there's just so many
bugs or mistakes in software in the
world and there's so many features that
humans wish existed in products present
and future that are to-do list so to
speak is way longer than will ever have
time to finish in our lifetimes and so I
think the prospect to having an
artificial intelligence boost our
productivity and work alongside us so to
speak as we try to solve problems is
just going to mean that you and I and
the world together can solve so many
more problems and move forward together
at an even faster rate all right next up
Sophia who asks how do microchips even
work it's just a green piece of metal
well here for instance we have a whole
bunch of microchips on what's called a
logic board or sometimes known as a
motherboard there's a lot of ports that
you might be familiar with for instance
like here are some ports for audio here
are some ports for networking here's
some ports for USB and some other
devices as well and those ports
meanwhile are connected to lots of
different chips on this board that know
how to interpret the signals from those
ports and perhaps the biggest chip on
this motherboard tends to be this thing
here called the CPU or the central
processing unit which is really the
brains of the computer and what you
can't necessarily quite see because most
of this is actually paint and not traces
but if I flip this around you'll
actually see in the right light and with
the right angle a whole bunch of traces
running up down left and right on this
logic board that's connecting all of
these various microchips and by Trace I
mean a tiny little wire that's been
etched into the top or the bottom of
this circuit board that connects two
parts thereon now what might these
microchips be doing well again they
might be simply interpreting signals
that are coming in from these ports two
they might be performing mathematical
operations doing something with those
signals in order to convert input into
output or they might just be storing
information ultimately in fact there's
all different types of memory on a logic
board like this be it Ram or ROM or the
like and so some of those chips might
very well be storing information for as
long as the computer is plugged in or in
some cases depending on the device even
when the power goes off alright next a
question from nkhe so if anyone can
learn coding what do computer scientists
do for four years in University
typically in an undergraduate program in
computer science or computer engineering
or a similar field someone spends much
more time learning about the field
itself than about programming
specifically so as such you might study
not only a bit of programming but also
mathematics certain fundamentals that
transcend the particular classes you
might have taken in middle school or
high school but that can be used to
solve Grand or real world problems you
might learn something about networks how
you can send information from point A to
point B you might learn about Graphics
how you can display things on the screen
or even create interactive animations or
the like you might learn how to leverage
certain ideas from mathematics and other
fields to implement your very own
artificial intelligence nowadays whereby
you use probability and statistics and
information more generally to try to
predict what a intelligent individual or
in this case computer might say in
response to a question so computer it's
science itself is a very broad field and
programming is really just a tool that
you tend to learn along the way from
Maya Shelby how do zeros and ones turn
into the internet well I think the
simplest answer there is that the
internet is built upon layers and layers
and layers of ideas and if we start at
the lowest of those levels zeros and
ones you have something called binary
where zeros and ones can be used to
represent any other numbers as well and
if we use more and more zeros and ones
more and more binary digits or bits so
to speak we can count up higher and
higher and higher and then if you and I
agree that all right well let's not just
use these patterns of zeros and ones to
represent numbers what if we reserve
some of these patterns to represent
letters of like the English alphabet and
then maybe you and I can decide to
reserve certain patterns of zeros and
ones to represent colors like red and
green and blue in combinations thereof
well once we have the ability to
represent colors we could then represent
whole pictures because what's a picture
on your phone or a computer screen well
it's really just a grid of dots Each of
which has its own color so this is all
to say that even if we start at this
lowest level of just zeros and ones so
long as you and I and all of the devices
we use agree to follow some standard
like this we can build these layers and
layers of abstraction so to speak on top
of one another until finally you and I
come up with a pattern of zeros and ones
that represents send this piece of of
information from me over there and thus
we have something like the internet
Majin Buu asks can someone that knows
computer science explain to me why
computers use binary coding and not
trinary when trinary is supposed to be
faster so it's not necessarily the case
that a trinary system which would use
three symbols for instance zero one and
two would necessarily be faster than
binary because binary using just zero
and one tends to be simpler to implement
and also more robust to potential errors
or if you're familiar with voltage
levels like in a battery it's very easy
for a computer to distinguish something
for like zero volts or three volts but
it gets a little harder if we try to
draw the line somewhere in between
because there's just a higher
probability that a computer might
mistake a a voltage level like 1.5 in
the middle is maybe being a little
closer to off than on or to on than off
here too is where even though there
might be mathematical efficiencies in
real world efficiencies to using trinary
otherwise known as ternary like a zero a
one and a two digit instead of just
zeros and ones it turns out because our
world runs on electricity nowadays and
there's so much momentum behind binary
that it just tends to be a net positive
Rachel P95 asks why is every Windows
solution have you tried restarting and
why does that always work so that's a
very heavy-handed solution to what are
typically just bugs or mistakes in
software for instance windows in this
case restarting a computer just starts
everything from scratch so all of the
computers short-term memory is lost and
everything starts in pristine condition
which is to say that it starts in
exactly the way that the programmers at
Microsoft intended without potentially
the distractions of the computer being
in some weird state or condition that
the programmers just didn't anticipate
maybe you clicked on some buttons in a
weird order maybe you opened a strange
file but you maybe you got the computer
into a state that just wasn't programmed
for properly Jason Whitmer now asks
what's the best operating system well
this is one of these questions in
Computing we would call a religious
question since it evokes a religious
debate as to which might be best of
course among the most popular operating
systems out there are windows and Mac OS
but there's also one you might not have
heard of which is called Linux which is
actually very omnipresent in the
Enterprise world so many of today's
servers actually run Linux so many of
today's desktops or laptops though run
Windows or Mac OS now that's not to say
you couldn't run all of those operating
systems in different contexts and some
of us do actually run Linux on our own
computers so a lot of it is really boils
down to personal preference I wouldn't
even say that there's one best operating
system but there tend to be correlations
between the operating systems people use
and the applications they have in mind
so windows for instance is so popular in
the world of PCS and desktops and
laptops Mac OS is to some extent
particularly in Academia in certain
countries but not necessarily on the
same scale Linux by contrast is again
very much used heavily in the
server-side industry but so is Windows
as well so a lot of the choice for
operating systems sometimes comes from
just what's most appropriate what's most
popular what's most supportive but some
of it comes too from just personal
preference of the engineer maybe the
first engineer that you hire to make one
of those decisions so it's more about
what what's best for you and not so much
best in general next Julio magnifico
asks why aren't computers getting
cheaper well computers or at least
computer parts inside of computers do
tend to get cheaper the catch is that
your expectations and my expectations
just keep Rising we want our phones our
laptops our desktops to do more and more
in the way of the software that they run
the games that we use and just how
quickly they perform for us so even
though some of those parts are getting
less expensive you and I want them to do
more and more and be faster and larger
in quantity and so as a result I dare
say that the price isn't going down as
far as you might hope that said nowadays
you can get for the same amount of money
from yesteryear much much more in the
way of computing power so arguably it's
working to our benefit in some cases
next up from Darrow nabila can someone
explain cloud computing to me like a
five-year-old cloud computing is
essentially you using someone else's
servers that someone is paying to rent
for instance or timeshare so this isn't
really a new idea or or new technology
rather it's a better branding of a
technique that's been used for years not
just in the computer world but in the
real world as well whereby someone like
Google or Microsoft or apple or others
nowadays might be able to afford lots
and lots and lots of servers and then
make those servers available in part to
me to you and many other customers as
well hey I'm Marcus hey Marcus well
Marcus asks how does computer memory
work think of computer memory as really
being driven by a whole bunch of
switches that can either be turned on
and off so for instance if I take this
here light switch which is currently off
I could simply say that this switch here
is representing the number zero in
binary but if I turn the switch on well
now I can say that I'm representing the
number one now of course I can only
count as high as 0 to 1 with a single
light switch but what if I bring over a
second light switch like this one here
if we start at zero in this way turn on
this switch first and claim that it's
one let me now be more creative and turn
this one off and this one on and now
claim this is how how a computer's
memory could represent the number two
and now if I turn this switch back on
giving me a fourth pattern this is how I
might represent the number three now of
course if we add more and more of these
switches more and more of these light
bulbs we can count even higher than
three and indeed that's what a
computer's memory is ultimately doing
it's using lots and lots of little tiny
switches otherwise known as transistors
to turn the flow of electricity on and
off and then it's got other types of
Hardware called for instance capacitors
that have a capacity to hold on to some
of that electricity just like the light
bulb there being on all right next
Donnie asks how do you explain web 3 to
people so web3 like web 2 and
retrospectively web one or really just
buzzwords that describe sort of phases
of the internet or the World Wide Web as
you and I know it for instance back in
the day when there was just the World
Wide Web now perhaps referred to as web
version one information was largely
static if you were to create a website
on the internet you would type up your
code you would type up your content you
would put it on a server somewhere and
someone could read that information but
it was you the web developer or you the
owner of the website that was creating
that content for other people to
actually read and consume in web 2 the
world became much more dynamic in recent
years whereby now websites tend to have
databases and they have more
sophistication so that a lot of the
content in websites today are actually
coming from me and from you so if you
think of any social media site it's not
the owners of those sites that are
creating most of the content it's you
and me as the users of those same
websites but in web 2 everything is
nonetheless very centralized whether
you're Twitter or Facebook now meta or
other companies all of that data even in
the world of social media that's coming
from me and you is actually being stored
centrally on those company servers so
web 3.0 or web 3 so to speak is really
about transitioning away potentially
from that very centralized model to one
that's more distributed where the data
that you and I are creating whereby the
data you and I are consuming is actually
distributed over multiple servers over a
technique called blockchain for instance
in some cases whereby there's not
necessarily one owner of that data but
really Collective ownership and
therefore verification that the data
Maybe indeed came from me and you next a
question from gomo tigers can someone
explain to me the difference between
firmware and software Hardware is
physical software is code WTF is
firmware firmware is really a synonym
for a type of software so firmware is
just software but it tends to be
software that comes built into your
hardware and you can think of in the
simplest scenario that firmware is
software that is just completely
integrated into the hardware and itself
cannot be changed or even upgraded but
that's a bit of an oversimplification
because even firmware typically when it
comes in a computer when it comes in a
phone or some other device can very
often be updated why because the
firmware is the software that's really
closest to the hardware and in that
sense it might very well be the most
important and if anything goes wrong
with The Firm where you might not even
be able to turn that device on whether
it's a phone or computer or even your
refrigerator nowadays alright that's all
the questions for today we hoped you
learned a little something along the way
we'll see you next time
[Music]